good afternoon everybody welcome to her
cabinet first of all I just like to
welcome cancer Richardson till his first
first ever cabinet and also thank Peter
Gould for accepting the business now as
I don't have much voice and it's
probably not gonna last
I've asked cancer the Brewster I think
would mind chairing this session thank
you my good afternoon councillors
members of the public and officers of
course and welcome to this cabinet
meeting this afternoon on the 10th of
February take first take first apologies
for absolutes if I can please we have no
apologies to thank you and declaration
of interest by councillors thank you
item 3 is to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 6th of January 2020
thank you very much and a seconder
happy to second that chair thank you
very much it's is it your wish that
those are signed as a correct record and
now have a show of hands please
thank you and then also to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 13th
of January 2020 thank you and a seconder
please and once again happy to
second-chair
and is it your wish that those me that
saw signs as a correct recorder that
meeting please the show of hands thank
you very much
how many petitions in accordance with
the councillors petitions being received
the questions were cancerous we've
received a question from Kelso John
Matheson which is in your table papers
along with the response thank you very
much
and item seven matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees can sort of well
would you like to speak to her please
Thank You chair yeah item seven which is
the general fund and four year outlook
overview and scrutiny Gerry welcomed the
additional well welcome the additional
half million pounds allocated to climate
change for the year 2021 and you'll have
seen the comments that were made during
that meeting there are just a couple of
outstanding queries there in paragraphs
20 not 19 to 20 22 and they are around
funding weather mid-south and District
Council will have to put funds into the
civil parking enforcement either as a
lump sum or more concerning is as an
ongoing expenditure is it going to break
even in the in the longer term or is
there going to be a going to be a profit
if the profit what's the profit going to
be used for and it are there funds are
there funds allocated if they are needed
I don't know if there's an answer to
that or whether whether we will get a
response to that but hopefully it has
been taken into account yes thank you
good questions I'm not sure the precise
details of how much this may or may not
be a money-making scheme unknown yet I
think it's it's designed to be revenue
neutral but in terms of the details of
what happens to the money and my
understanding is it gets returned to the
County Council but perhaps if I could
ask us to clarify
for Thank You curse please come in yes
okay so in terms of off-street which are
the council car parks any revenue so
from the car park terrace or from the
tickets that are issued for enforcement
that income comes back into mid Suffolk
District Council and that will help pay
for the whole parking function so of
course we're having a combination of hip
switch and West doing that function on
our behalf so initially that goes to pay
for it and I believe that there will be
a deficit so it currently we're under
two deficit and I put I absolutely
assume that that's going to continue for
a while at least while there are small
parking charges available when you know
a small amount of income being made by
the council on parking which is used to
subsidize the service so that is likely
to run at a subsidy in terms of on
street so that is the County Council's
function who they have decided to
devolve across Suffolk to local
authorities again that function is being
done by its switch and West Suffolk so
any income generated by those
enforcement tickets will go back to the
county council will pay for the parking
function and then they will choose to do
what they will with any surplus from
that could I just ask one more question
and you said the county will do what
they will but I think that has to be
that has to be traffic and transport
related it can't be just build a new
school buy a new book or whatever thank
you thank you and the outputs one from
joined Avenue overview and scrutiny we
are taking actually at that point on the
agenda where that will be relevant thank
you and Ida made the forthcoming just
sorry yes sorry we missed that one HRA
sorry Keith Thank You chair yes the HR
account budget and four year outlook
Committee were generally satisfied with
the H HR a budget but at some time not
necessarily today committee would like
to see a time scale for the new house
building there is a program of building
council houses and we would we would
like to see when that when that's going
to be taking place what the what the
program is for for those projects but
I'm not expecting an answer now but
would like one in due course thank you
do we need to take the recommendations
well you pick them up and about you
the forthcoming decisions list and does
anyone have any questions there
no thank you and we moved into the
general fund budget MC a 1943 the
general fund budget for 2021 in the
four-year outlook and our last
Chancellor Whitehead to give us the
report on that please Thank You chairman
or vice chair
I brought the draft general fund budget
for 2021 to cabinet in January and the
subsequent to that overview screen II
had the opportunity to review this draft
budget at their January meeting and
grateful to have you scrutiny for the
diligence they applied to that process
and the questions they raised and
details their considerations are
included in our pack today at pages 17
through 21
now having sent aware actress was a
thorough introduction to the draft
budget at our January meeting and with
this budget also having been through it
to an in-depth briefing by our finance
team to an or member briefing in January
I don't intend to take up a great deal
of our time today with yet another
lengthy introduction but I must advise
cabinet there have been some recent
revisions to the draft budget numbers
these arise from the completion of the
statutory business rates declarations
which are based on the end of January
numbers and therefore included
information that only became available
after our previous considerations of the
budget and these changes which are
positive are ye good news are set out in
the tabled additional report so just in
terms of budget I'd like to reinforce a
small number of key observations we've
had a deliberate policy of minimizing
the use of new hands burn listed
balancing our budget over the last few
years and indeed none of our actual
annual out turn
since new husband has started has taken
a penny from new herons bonus for our
normal counsel running costs and
likewise for 2021 we use no new homes
bonus to balance the books and paragraph
810 in our report clearly shows why this
is important because new house bonus
will fall away to zero by year 2023 24
we also all know that cap central
government support grants have fallen
away over the last few years and that's
why we've been determined that our
council consider its own two feet by
generating our own income to support our
expenditure and just to recap we do that
by our various pooled investments it
gives us an income stream by building up
Safeco 250 million in secured real
estate assets with quality rental income
streams we grow our tax base for to new
housing and that provides every 1% extra
a year to our tax base and then finally
improve modest below inflation increases
for example this year were proposing 1.6
6% to increase our council tax that
increases 2-pound 76 for a bandy
property which works out at just 28
pence a month extra the typical persons
paying on a 10 month directly berrak
debit and a budget for the year shows a
healthy surplus when I seen left having
set aside to quite large sums of money 1
for 1 billion pounds and one for 1/2
million pounds the 1 million pound was
setting aside to a commercial
development risk management reserve and
that's for our in district developments
of brownfield and greenfield sites that
covers middle school sites that need a
market headquarter site and our large
gateway 14 site these sort of
developments are never risk-free and so
it's better just best to have this extra
contingency whilst we have a surplus in
hand half a million power putting into a
climate change initiatives interesting
ideas emerge from several meetings we
had with opposition groups some of these
have been passed across the climate
change task and finish group for scoping
and refining and in the meantime several
our offices are was put in because
work examining these proposals that work
is ongoing but it's crystal clear to me
that real action on climate change will
need a real money set aside and
accordingly we've put half a million
pound aside as the starter in 2021
and make more may come forward from the
greater efficiency fund going forward
more details of those initiatives are
set out will be set out in the corporate
outputs report that we speak a bit later
we are spending quite a bit of our
earmarked reserves join next year but
reserves and totals should still be over
10 million pounds by the end of 2021 as
set out in paragraph 7.6 and you mean
that thing I'm actually ignoring still
that costs out special and ring-fenced
and it's great to have such a healthy
cushion as we go forward as that lets us
invest in our leisure facilities
business development and all the various
emerging environmental initiatives the
budget report also covers capital and
all the detail of that is in Appendix B
fourteen point nine million pounds of
intent to spend which includes the
balance of tsypko needham marks Needham
Market Lakes visitor center cafe and
leisure center developments
Kamlesh we'll also know to the proposed
change to reduce the twenty five percent
discount for an occupied and unfurnished
residential dwellings from three months
down to 28 days that brings in more
council tax acts as an incentive not to
keep properties vacant whilst giving a
long lost time to reload their
properties our following concerns raised
by various members I can confirm that
empty properties arising through the
death of residence and the granting of
probate are subject to a different
policy regime and lastly a didn't this
report since it last came to cabinet is
section 12 pay policy statement which
starts on page 56 now in previous years
this has been brought forward in a
separate report but I understand that
many councils now incorporate it into
their budget reporting and it strikes me
as a sensible thing to do
and as always I'm happy to answer any
questions on the report the finance team
are here to assist me as there's
obviously a great deal of detail within
this report but firstly then I'd like to
propose the full suite of recommendation
set out and report to section 3 plus the
tabled update paper and that's for
someone to second that thank you thank
you I'm delighted to second the
reporting and the recommendations I
think it finds the ideal balance between
risk and opportunity and should satisfy
both the cautious and the progressive
and I think it it it sets the council on
a good course thank you very much I know
there any questions for the cabinet
member or officers okay so he bone
thank you very much chair firstly I
understood that the final finance
settlement was made on 6th of February
so just a few days ago and I just
wondered what the impact of that was on
the budget if any secondly the cabinet
member for finance refers to the new
home as bonus being in its last year and
then you can use the expression it would
fall away however government already
said that it wants to consult on a new
replacement incentive that to replace
the new homes bonus said the expectation
is that there will be something to
replace it and it won't be 0 I'd also
have like to thank the administration
for liaising with us on our budget
proposals and I'm very pleased to see
some of those being taken forward
there's a couple that I would still have
wished to see more work be done on which
included improving our sustainability in
our own house building and promoting
electric vehicles and councillor
Madison's question I mean I think we
should be ashamed that we've only got
two AV charging points in mid Suffolk
that really is very very poor and we did
put forward some proposals to improve
that and have more AV charging points
and thirdly to you know I visit Stowe
market but I think more people should
and we did put some proposals forward
about attracting more people to Stowe
market and the visioning work that's
been going on there in our view has been
taken quite a long time and we would
like to see that progressing far faster
and I wouldn't in any way but any of
these initiatives as being aggressive I
think they're we could do a lot more at
this council
specific questions of other than whether
the finance settlement from the six of
ever has changed the I still got concern
about car park income and in relation to
the civil parking enforcement because we
get
we retain about 600,000 pounds of income
according to the budget book so I
wouldn't want all that to slip away but
perhaps I'm working on to that secondly
the outcomes were all we've seen about
the corporate plan is corporate outputs
we haven't actually seen any outcomes
and so how are they being costed and
what would happen if if they need extra
funding is that is that covered we have
got 9.2 million which is a huge sum in
the general the the growth and
efficiency fund as it were and I'm
concerned that the amount that we've put
forward and reserves for neighborhood
plans is very low given that we should
really be supporting them and once we
get of joint local plan more underway
those local plans and those neighborhood
plans will be needing to be reviewed and
we should be supporting those
communities with that and and I'd like
to see more funding put forward for that
so specific questions a car park income
whether the outcomes for corporate
outputs are being covered and if we can
if we're sure that we've got sufficient
funding therefore neighbourhood blends
thank you chairman thank you so if I
just referred to Catherine for the
information on the final settlement it's
a no change the figures were exactly as
in the provisional settlement s
so just to just address some of the
other issues that councillor ebin raised
yes the new homes bonus I mean we've
seen how the government tinker with it
and the it is going out to zero and we
know something it's coming through to
replace it but as of yet we have no clue
what that might be
we do know that in any settlements going
forward counties and unitary seem to be
being favored over districts and and
also any new scheme could just be a
temporary nature so it's just best to
try and make sure we can do what we can
do day to day without having recourse to
that the table papers that before you
show a communal cumulative surface
through to the end of twenty to twenty
four two point two eight two million so
there is still a lot of scope I would
say for fine-tuning a lot of the points
that you raised whether it be
neighborhood planning expenditure or
roaming the evey points would work in
stone market a lot housing
sustainability we've got the half
million set aside and we still got a lot
of great efficiency spend money to spend
on that so there are a lot of
initiatives that do need more refining
but just council the ghouls sad to see
this budget is people like myself would
like to Redding's on the cautious side
there's still plenty money that we spend
and calorie burn I think some of the
questions you tackle there they will
become more apparent within the later
document for the corporate plan and if
we can take those there I think that
would be more appropriate do we have any
other questions counsel field thank you
wondered whether there are any good
questions left and just again thank you
for the opportunity to discuss some
aspects of the budget and the ones of
our proposals were adopted I think are a
good choice we're pleased to see that
particularly perhaps my own views on
enforcement to see something as taking
more an effective action there will be
very good and certainly meet the
requirements of many of our residents a
little sad to see that you didn't find
it possible to support the views that
highways a voice to planning meetings
could do with the boost to get solutions
which are more to the liking of
residents and more to the benefit of the
economy but nevertheless I think we
understand that point on new homes bonus
I would just come count comment that yes
the county bonuses as as as you well
know a candy counters where one knows
the county's pretty short of cash and
the benefit of giving cash to the county
is it will actually spend it to get to a
question looking on page 49 I just had
an issue about pension fund assumptions
I'm pretty sure again that you're
thinking of the other place they are
assuming a 1% reduction per annum in in
pension payments and I had a feeling
that there are later papers in this set
it's easy to lose them among 260 pages
but I thought there were light apologies
that said something slightly different
to the
it's on page 49 I he led me to believe
once again there was a a slight
reduction as the pension fund is I
believe pretty well funded at the moment
so I wondered if there's a what someone
could point me in the right direction on
that one so why did please thank you for
that certainly my eight years on this
council cast be a lot of good questions
and looking particularly at the pension
side of it yes the bottom page 49
it says the the 1% per annum reduction
from 2021 to 222 223 being built into
these numbers but perhaps caffeine's
want to just add any more - no I was
literally gonna confirm the same that we
are building in a 1% reduction for the
next three years so for 20 21 21 22 and
20 23 24 because that's the next three
years of the the next triennial
valuation so the fund position has
approved so we're taking the decision to
take 1% add I'm just confirming that
your later analysis is the one part one
officer and she says the same thing does
it always thought he was saying
something slightly different so I can
double-check that but hopefully it does
if not I'll correct it for both of the
council report Thank You counsel Willem
Thank You chair um there's an urgent
need for more clarity around
neighbourhood planning this was brought
home at the recent development Control
Committee on 22nd of January has one or
two of those within cabinet are fully
aware this need is bound to increase as
the joint local plan gets nearer to
adoption I get the feeling that
currently planning policy staff are
really struggling with their current
workload and this is this is bound to
increase the pressure is bound to
increase in my view so what shouldn't we
be doing something now not waiting thank
general I think it's fair to say that
the pressure on all officers in relation
to every surface is going to increase
over time as demand for our services
increases neighborhood planning is no
exception to that rule planning
generally I think it's probably fair to
say you can never have enough planners
no matter how much planning work there
is but as we sit here at this point in
time the assessment from a strategic
Director perspective and more
particularly for an assistant director
perspective is that we've got the right
level of resource but clearly at any
point in time if we think we need more
then we will come back to offer to
members and seek more resource in that
regard the majority of the work remember
of course in relation to neighborhood
planning is done by that village or town
our role is to support them in that
regard not to do the work for them they
are the experts in their area but we
think we've got the right level of
resource at this time thank you are
there any other questions
no in that case I have a proposal
seconder and you very much
and we'll move on then to report number
MCA 1944 which is a housing revenue
account HRA budget
mm sorry 2020 and the longer term
outlook cancel why hit please yes thank
you again I'd now like to introduce
cabinet paper 1944 which is the housing
revenue account budget for 2221 and its
longer-term outlook
I brought the draft HRA budget here in
January and it's subsequently being
reviewed later in that month by overview
and scrutiny and their observations are
set out in our pack on pages 23 through
27 there have been some minor revisions
those draft numbers as workers continue
to fine-tune the figures with the result
of the deficit for the year which we
previously said would be six seventeen
thousand is now five hundred and
sixty-four thousand as I said in my
January introduction there's been many
positive developments and improvements
commenced during this current year
arising from the fundamental review of
the housing service undertaken in 1920
this has identify savings efficiencies
an income-generating opportunities to
achieve a sustainable business plan for
the future members we can read those
details in Section seven eight of the
report from April 20 we are now allowed
to increase the council tax rents by a
Consumer Price Index plus 1% this works
out at a two point seven percent
increase that's up to four years of
government impose one percent annual
rent reductions so a house with a
typical weekly rent of eighty pound
before the four years reductions came
into force will have a ripped weekly
rent after this 2.7 cent increase of
seventy eight pounds nine
- so wall tennis will still be paying
less rent for the same property in April
20 than they were in April 15 the
maintaining gallery's rents at the same
level in US 1920 nobody no increases
their proposing to increase sheltered
housing service charges by 2 pound I
know at our last meeting council eben
raised her concerns about this increase
that's a follow up for us the finance
team for more analysis to be done in
this area that's now being done and it
shows a 2 pound increase there was less
than a half way to eliminating the
deficit and an ideal will there would be
no deficit and no cross subsidy from
general non shelter tenants and
accordingly
two pounds a week is the minimum amount
of increase we can recommend this year
my participating more work can be done
in this area over the course of 2021 to
see what cost savings may be achievable
to minimize future increases these
charges following utility cost increases
we are proposing to increase sheltered
housing by 5 percent or 62 pence a week
these are all set out in the report
recommendations the HRA budget includes
a marked increase in our new build an
acquisition program the capital cost set
out in Appendix A the next four years 44
million will be spent of which
three-quarters of that service forecast
be spent in the first two years that's
funded by capital receipts grants
borrowings and revenue contributions
again Appendix A has those details
working with it I see me this will
equate 185 affordable homes in 85 shared
ownership homes major sites for
development include need a market in
Stowe Market middle school sites and
building all these council homes must be
great news for anyone struggling to find
a new home locally borrowing levels are
set out in the graph on paragraph six
point three shows in debt peaks at 20 to
23 but then Falls away quite steadily in
fact halves over fifteen years and of
course supporting all this current
year's budget is a 30-year HRA business
plan which we produce on a rolling basis
to ensure HOA plans are sustainable in
the longer term housing is a specialist
day of the council not pleased to say
that Galvin Fisk our ad for housing by
housing in communities
Cavanaugh colleague council Blackmun and
our finest team here to assist me in any
questions that might arise in this
report but first I'd like to move the
recommendation set out in paragraph
three plus the updated tables and I'd
like to ask my colleague counsel flat
when if she's prepared to second them
thank you yes
Thank You chair very happy to second
this report thank you thank you
oh there any questions Barry Barry
Thank You chair and Thank You councillor
why I had following up on that on my
previous question of although then that
said sits another question for me as to
whether then that means next year we'll
be doing another two pounds with week
increase but ISIL I'll leave that on
there at the moment but my question
really would be what are we actually
doing for our shelter tenants to ensure
that their bills are as low as possible
and that's in the widest sense of the of
that inter in terms of actual heating
systems as well as whether their homes
are for the insulin well insulated and
her PV on the roof and so on and my
second question if I may is with regards
to PV across the housing stock I'm just
interested to know if we've actually
achieved the maximum as it were in terms
of the house the homes that have got
those panels on them whether there are
other opportunities whether they be on
garage roofs or on you know above other
stocks other that buildings that the
council owns
are we actually maximizing the
opportunities for PV thank you very much
thank you
cancel the White House he's putting his
hand up sir
oh I'll kick off with this Oh certainly
when looking at the cost of sheltered
housing it certainly is an expensive
process isn't it out about that but the
we will do it an in-depth look at our
costs there and perhaps Gabby might like
to just say a few words on terms of the
this sort of cost drivers etc Thank You
chair just in response to to calorie
burns question there are a number of
plans
large-scale capital improvement programs
on some of our larger shared housing
schemes this year to upgrade and provide
more energy-efficient and low-cost
communal heating systems using air
source technology of the alike and I
think we're actually out to contract on
on two schemes at the moment coming back
to the wider question obviously the
shared housing service is only one part
of the overall housing service we are
continually always actively looking at
the cost drivers for those services and
how we can reduce those costs which in
turn obviously maximize the amount of
income we receive from council tenants
rents and I think within the corporate
outcomes and the home strategy we've
talked about a wider review of shared
housing in the forthcoming months and
and year to consider what what is shared
housing in its more wider context
because we know we've got an aging
population but we like so also know that
some of our housing isn't of of a high
demand so what are the challenges there
in terms of providing the best possible
accommodation for older people so I
fully expect that review to start later
this year
thank you just to come back only the
second point counselor baby bro raised
regarding the PV panels going back to
when these were first introduced and
before present ad for housing to come to
post I did notice that the worst some
for example maize and X in my area where
they look perfect for PV panels but
because of the complications of sharing
electricity generated between various
tenants rather than just you know being
one house the decision at that time was
taken not to put panels on on the roof
of course now the present I think put it
now would have a different tariffs to
what was there what several years ago
but I think it's must be more important
as being to get the system up and
running properly there's been quite a
lot of compound concerns a lot of
perhaps late revenues and a lot of
maintenance and repair issues that have
to be sorted out first before I think we
perhaps now may be able to turn our
attention to see if there are any other
option extras going forward get some
field
just one point of the sea on sheltered
housing the the alternatives are
sheltered housing that care homes are
cost more per week than shelter housing
costs per month so just a thought our
question really about the capital spend
and future ambitions we seem to have a
program here that lasts until 20 to 23
it would seem obviously we we do get a
return from from our investment and that
you might can take a view that
continuing to invest that return so that
you steadily increase the housing stock
or or possibly replace the stock where
these obsolete is that the right work
that requires replacing to meet modern
environmental standards might be a more
farsighted view is there any intention
to see these programs continue and form
you know continuous perhaps 30-year
investment process
Gavin can you come in please thank you
um Castle fields correct in that it does
look like the capital program in
relation to potentially new build and
acquisitions starts the tail off after
20 to 23 we are doing a lot of work with
our HR a business plan consultants as to
what the HRA can afford in the longer
term over the next thirty years
obviously any new debt has to be paid
for we will be working with the cabinet
and with the portfolio holder to
understand what that is and what that
means in terms of level of our our
ambition in terms of our new homes
program so that that won't be taking
place over the forthcoming months and
within the corporate outputs and
outcomes there is the plan to review the
HRA business plan in its entirety this
year so that I would expect to support
conversations in relation to the
organization's plan to deliver new homes
in the future thank you can I just point
out your paragraph 5 6 seems to indicate
is this is a good thing to continue to
do thank you are there any other
questions
no in the case I have a proposal in a
seconder and I've asked for a show of
hands please all those in favor thank
you sorry move on then to the councillor
whitehead show still with with joint
capital investment and treasury
management strategies 2020 to 2021 okay
continuing my show
Thank You third report I'm introducing
today is the joint capital investments
in treasury management strategies 2021
as report 1945 which starts on page 113
of our pact this people have sent it to
full counsel at the end of February
there's already been subject to full
scrutiny by joint audit and Standards
Committee this is a joint paper as a
strategies cover both Weber and Lucifer
and indeed all the many tables within
report share the details for both paper
and mazovick this report is produced
annually and there have been no
significant changes in format this year
but of course all the debt or the data
contain my report has been updated to
reflect latest capital expenditure
investment and borrowing and the latest
treasury management investments and
borrowing positions of the council the
information required is set out in the
sip for treasury management code of
practice and a Prudential code both of
which were published in 2017 along with
the MHC LG investment guidance which was
published in 2018 now in this
introduction I could spend considerable
time talking you through all the various
appendices within the 59 page of this
report but I am conscious that we do
have a very extensive cabinet agenda
before us today so so it made more time
we just to open report up to questions
as I said earlier this report is also
being scrutinized already by the joint
audience standards committee
so I'll propose now the list of
recommendations
set out in Section three plus the
updated tangled adjustments on page 113
114 with the report and particularly I
like to draw the attention of members to
recommendation of three point eight
which is new for this year and arises
from the joint audit and Standards
Committee scrutiny thank you thank you
very much
are there any questions proposal there
from counsel I waited because I'm
willing to second it in there was yes so
have you made the recommendation so
Castle there's just obviously it's a
second do you second to thank you I know
are there any questions in
Thank You Jeff there's nobody else um
I'm I'm confused I don't forgot the
wrong e the wrong version of the papers
but on page 140 there are two tables
there Table four
and on my version there's no numbers in
the table how can we see what the total
investment exposure is if we haven't got
any numbers in the table
i chair my second question was has have
cabinet read the papers well there would
be no investment equals no no exposure
yeah good idea but I think we have got
some significant exposure
we're just trying to find a version of
the report that's got the nut the
numbers easy I'm assuming the numbers
would have been in the report that went
to George doing audience standards so
not quite sure how they've ended up as
blank but we'll just see if we can find
them correctly
not quite sure how work cabinet would
wish to handle this offer now got a
version with the numbers in I could read
them out or we could circulate them and
we'll make sure they're in the final
version for for the council papers so so
happy to do either way can you read them
out please Catherine I'll only do mid
suffix unless anybody particularly wants
to wants to hear beta papers and so for
mid suffix starting with 2018 19 the
number for the treasury management
investments is twelve point three and
the capital investments 30 so that gives
a total exposure of forty two point
three 2019 twenty or so that was actual
but that figure forecast for 1924 the
current year treasury management
investments thirteen point six eight
capital investments forty five point
seven total exposure fifty nine point
three eight twenty twenty-one treasury
management investments thirteen point
one seven capital investments fifty nine
point two nine total seventy two point
four six twenty one twenty two treasury
management investments thirteen point
zero nine capital investment sixty four
point one one total exposure seventy
seven point two twenty two twenty three
treasury management investments 13 point
zero three cash and capital investments
sixty four point one one total exposure
seventy seven point one four and finally
twenty three twenty four treasury
management investments thirteen point
zero one
capital investment sixty 4.11 total
exposure seventy seven point one two and
apparently those speakers were in the
report that went to join order in
standards so I'm not quite sure what's
happened in just pulling this report
together chair for the avoidance of
doubt they are they are millions of
pounds they're not percentages they're
okay it doesn't matter did we did we do
need to know what the units are but they
are millions of pounds risk that we are
exposed to I believe message to new
investments didn't have any comment with
that
and the large part of the figures you're
talking about there is the investment in
gateway 14 which obviously is a is a
significant investment for the council
so that's that's a large part of what
that is
okay
like I mean if assistant investments
have considered them okay I don't see
obviously it hasn't come to all these to
our members here but until Katherine
just gave us those figures and obviously
with gateway 14 we are going to have
some large expenditure well there any
other questions yes cancel field just
looking at Table six on page one for one
this is noticing the difference between
the rate of return on treasury
management investments which depending
on what year you put picked 1920s 3.04
percent against if co2 at one point five
eight percent and then various it seems
to vary quite considerably as year as
the years progress gateway fourteen in
limited indeed he gives her a higher
investment return than anything I was
just wondering if you like him why are
we doing this if go to if triggering
management investments give you a higher
rate of return what am I missing
here's the white hood please I would I
believe that the Cisco to reduction will
be based on the fact that borrowing cost
was gonna be compared to the borrowing
costs we incurred on Cisco one gateway
fourteen at the moment is just the
return on the monies lent by the council
to the Gateway fourteen company passed
it undertakes that
velopment so the actual real return and
profit on that will take the bill not
longer to ultimately finalize but that's
it really is just a turn on the money
lent there at the moment and the various
treasury management investments are
different different sort of competitors
if coal its basic blending risk and
investment between investment funds and
for example the real estate the whole
point of investing across various assets
dreams is to spread the risk and return
are there any other questions
if not we'll take it to a vote we have a
proposer and seconder all those in favor
thank you sorry we move on to mca 1916
446 which is the business rates
discounts policy and I was cancer white
had to come back it thank you and please
that and she is my fourth and final
report as agenda item 12 which is report
mca 1946 on business rates discounts
policy the government recently announced
in the Queen's speech in December
further changes to business rate
discounts as these are temporary by
nature the government has not enacted
primary legislation the instead is
relying on local authorities using their
existing discretionary relief powers the
discount changes proposed are to
increase the retail discount from one
third to one half to add in cinemas and
music venues to the scheme and to extend
the duration of newspaper discounts and
also to introduce an additional discount
for post I understand that there are 44
poems in mid Suffolk they will be
covered by this new discount scheme
which allows it to 1,000 pounds discount
for purple which was quite in total to
44,000 a key point for members to
understand this at this relief to local
businesses we fully reimbursed by
central government so our local
businesses benefit from the business
rate reductions but this comes at no
cost to ourselves as the local authority
now the business rate bills for 2021
that used to be sent out in early March
and from both an administrative point of
view and also for those receiving their
bills it must surely be preferable for
those bills to reflect these new
discounts our time is very tight to
process all these changes but I know the
stuffed our shared revenues
I will relish relish such a challenge
further details of the application of
various discounts were merged since the
report was written the recommendation is
section 3.1 delegates authority to our
assistant that service assistant
director for corporate resources and
consultation we both myself and our
council leader to agree and send to SRP
for processing all these business rate
discounts and please to propose that
recommendation would ask for someone to
second it as always we stand ready to
answer any questions members may have
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you all are there any questions
I actually had one which I noticed on
the paperwork that charity shops didn't
qualify they weren't considered to
qualify for this discount and whereas in
our own paper they dude I'm just
wondering if there is any benefit out of
the way that Baber are doing there's I
think
disco sorry charity shops already get a
substantial release from from the
business rates your thoughts might be on
that concern there's a whole scheme of
applications for various discounts which
um Andrew first up he is here and he can
advise us on that particularly in terms
of the charity shorts which I believe
get an 8% mandatory and a 20%
discretionary discount from your suffer
but under if you'll just talk through
how the various discounts apply and the
complications you have to work through
Thank You chair yeah sounds quite aids
is correct the church shops will receive
mandatory relief for 20% and when we do
top them up for it eighty percent and we
do talk not with 20% discretionary
relief which is slightly different to
how I even deal with their relief in
applying the retail relief in the pub
relief there is a pecking order so you
have to do all the mandatory reliefs
first followed by the discretion month
to pub relief being the very last
discount me award and so with there is
that discrepancy between the two
authorities so diminishes in theory as
you as you go on and around yep thank
you very much for that
thank you
the next item on the agenda is in 2019
223 to support delivery of the joint
corporate plan and almost counselor Mori
please - thank you
since applicants proposed for 2019 224
these output support the delivery of the
six strategic priorities of entering the
corporate plan agreed by mid-summer
Council in October each of the six
priorities are supported by their own
strategies the environment strategy
currently under development and being
influenced by the member task force and
the world being strategy sheduled for
development in the coming months I will
also be refreshing your economic
development strategy these strategies
will set out the key outcomes under each
strategic theme and will be underpinned
by detailed action plans corporate
performance indicators are currently
being revised for 2022 2021 onwards to
align that with this new corporate blend
we want to emphasize that yeah what
identified at this stage are not
exhaustive and we fully expect to add to
these over the next few years indeed
following further discussions within the
cabinet and also discussions with our
green group and a live demo Liberal
Democrat group I would like to add five
additional outputs to the
recommendations as in the papers table
today in the main these builder workers
has already started with need further
development these are to promote
sustainable new homes across the
district by increasing available advice
the dress fuel poverty while improving
energy efficiency and reducing Goulburn
improve tree cover across the district
improve democratic engagement with
residents and review and improve
planning enforcement I'm really pleased
that our green and LibDem groups are so
aligned with our administration's
thinking on these things in order to
achieve these strategic outcomes we know
how important it is to have the right
resources in place we're required
following preparation of business cases
bids will be submitted to the growth and
efficiency fund and to the proposed
climate change earmarked river reserve
to support activities related to the
environment monitoring and reporting on
the delivery of the corporate plans
outputs will take place in a number of
ways including through the quarterly
performance reports to complete finally
we recognize the importance of all
member engagement in the corporate blown
and outputs and support the
recommendation from overview and
scrutiny in this regard an or member
briefing session will take place in
March this year to provide an
opportunity for members to gain a
greater overall understanding of the
straight six strategic priorities in the
corporate plan thereafter throughout the
year all member briefing sessions will
be themed to cover one strategic
priority each work is underway to ensure
that as many member development and
engagement sessions as possible will be
accessible remotely through a range of
methods the same is being considered
more generally for the rollout of the
joint corporate plan I move the
recommendation to agree the outputs for
2019 223 set
appendix one of the main report and also
the five additional outputs listed at
paragraph 1.2 of the addendum report
table today I also move the
recommendation to agree that the
environmental outputs relevant to the
parameters of the climate change task
force I'll refer to that group thank you
Jeff and I would ask for a second I
thank you thank you I'm happy to second
didn't you
and do we have any questions
oh yes sorry sorry counsel well um you
going to comment on your Thank You chair
there was much debate at overview
scrutiny
generally with suffolk members wish for
more details and bobo members were
unconcerned din fact weber were not
clear as to whether or not they actually
wanted it to be a joint meeting or
whether they were quite happy for mid
suffer to to look at the outputs
brochure document what we call it none
of the members there could really
understand the real value of the
corporate outputs paper since it
contained few measurable outputs and it
would not be possible to measure it
performance against the actions listed
in the in the booklet of outputs so the
resolution from the the joint committee
was that a committee urges the cabinet
to find a range of methods to engage
with all members to understand the
linkage between the corporate plan and
the corporate outputs and explained the
role of member working groups in
developing strategies and action plans
and i think some of that the leader
addressed in her introduction but i
think it is important that that members
do become involved and to become
involved they need the opportunities to
become involved because this is
potentially a very important document
but without any dates against the the
outputs and
measurable outputs it is of limited use
thank you very much potentially document
there's no doubt in my mind whatsoever
this is a very important document and
many ways different ways to engage with
our members as I stated to my
introduction and these clear crude a
range of measured measures including
webcasting or remote access
we'll be investigating those months
thank you are there any other questions
cancel any burn thank you very much um
chair firstly I'd like to thank the
leader and for and the portfolio holder
the finance for the discussions that we
had that council have filled and myself
initia initiated back in November when
we approached the administration with
our draft budget proposals and we I
appreciate the discussions that we've
had both in relation to the budget and
the corporate plan in that regard
obviously we're pleased to see the
things that are coming forward but then
again disappointed of the things that
aren't coming forward so but that's
probably a conversation for for another
day I think although specifically I am
disappointed that we're not going
further with regards to our own housing
developments and ensuring things that
housing is far more environmentally
efficient and we were able to actually
enable that tenants living in our own
housing stock have really low bills and
so therefore they're at less risk of
rent arrears and they're more able to go
and get that particular types of
employment because they're less worried
about their bills and so on
and health benefits if you're in a
healthy house and so on so I think we
should we should be really far far more
ambitious there and I think that I think
there's a will here we get shown by the
seminar that councillor Matheson
arranged on Friday afternoon with when
there was standing room only
when looking at kind of new methods of
house building so I would like to see
far more ambition from the council in
that regard and others other ones I I
really think you know one evey point
charging point in stone market that I've
mentioned I think that really is pretty
poor and we should be doing a lot more
more there but there's more I could go
into detail there but but specific
questions I think I'm concerned that
we've got this document that's what
corporate outputs and obviously what we
need to have that is outcomes and we
need to have outcomes that are actually
measurable for residents and for our for
our district but the finite the new
financial year starts in six weeks time
so I haven't you know I'm assuming that
you guys here in the cabinet will have
seen documents saying what the corporate
you know say draft out there out comes
with measurable items on those but you
know if we're going to start measuring
this from 50 April we need to you know
big it you know something should be here
I mean it if not at this cabinet meeting
then I'd hope that you've got something
coming to your March 1 so my question is
is what you know what what are the
corporate out outcomes and then the
question that I was asking then the
budget session have we got the funding
that if needs be you know in terms of
delivering those outcomes are we are we
confident that we've got the funding to
you know attach those and I think the
answers gonna be yes from the growth and
efficiency fund but just again just to
confirm that please think
very much I lost the chief executive
please to answer to that if I can just
pick up part of that possibly won't
answer all the question but I'll try to
and so I'm I'm hopeful that this is the
first and last time you ever receive a
list of corporate outputs they're very
deliberately phrased outputs because
there's no point trying to kid ourselves
that these are outcomes and so they're
very clearly phrased in that way that
the outcomes that I've believe all
counselors would wish to seek should be
already enshrined within your six key
strategic priorities and particularly
within the six key strategies in that
regard I say six and you will appreciate
members that I've said before about the
fact that two of those six are works in
progress and in fact appearing on the
list of outputs in terms of activity
that needs to happen those in particular
being the environment strategy and the
well-being strategy or rather turning
the sports and leisure strategy into a
well-being strategy so those outcomes
should be enshrined within there but as
you will also have heard me say
previously that where those strategies
either ceased to be effective then we
should be revisiting those and that's
not to revisit the outcomes per se but
it is to revisit the tactics that go
alongside delivery against those
outcomes so when I say this is the first
and the last time you receive it like
this our anticipation is that you will
begin to receive this tripod content but
as action plans with measurable outcomes
alongside them as part of each of those
strategies so that you end up with a
suite of six action plans and probably
more usefully for all members is to to
compile that into one document but
effectively a suite of six action plans
that aligns to your six priorities that
each of which is supported by six
strategies so you just not see how that
picture builds up I would just take
issue with one component there are dates
within this list of outputs so if
there's any concern that there are
missing dates I wouldn't say that there
are dates for all of them that some of
them are more developed than others and
where they are and they're very clear
they haven't put dates in terms of the
31st or the first of a month but they
are linked as you'll see to two seasons
at the moment but those dates are there
but as the leader outlined at the outset
the intention is that
alongside this that your performance
management framework is updated to make
sure that you can see those measurables
that in you're receiving the indicators
and the confidence that the things that
you want to see delivered are actually
being delivered and one last observation
I suppose is that this is a complete
transformation to where you were this
time last year not least because you've
had an election in-between and you've
adopted a brand new corporate plan so
that's why this feels potentially
slightly piecemeal because you are
transitioning from one version of how
you delivered services to a different
version in order to make sure that you
get delivered the things that you want
to get delivered and similarly the
proposals put forward by the green group
and the Liberal Democrat group that
weren't formally mentioned by the leader
the reason they haven't been added is
because I believe the leaders of you
whether she could speak for herself
usually is that they're already in there
that those are already insurance it's
not that they've been left out because
they're not deemed too important they
are deemed to be important it's just
they were already in there so you'll see
reference for example within the outputs
to policies in relation to electric for
charging vehicle points for exactly that
reason I just wanted to be clear for the
cabinet and full members that there's
haven't been missed so it's big thank
you yes if I'm a chairman I'll come back
yes policy is lovely but I don't know
I'd like to see a faction on the on the
on the ground but thank you for that -
two points really I think that the
leader mentioned member engagement as
did the and chair of overview and
scrutiny and I think one thing that
sometimes gets forgotten is this 34
councillors in this authority and we're
all we all want to see things you know
we all want to contribute and we're not
you know we're here to kind of improve
the lives of people in this district and
do what we can for that and so please
don't you know please involve all
members in terms of of how this is
progressing because we can
we've all got experience with all the
awards that we've got various things
happening and we've got all got
contributions to
and secondly I'd like to see more in
terms of social return on investment you
know we talk about what's this buzzword
the buzz phrase invests today but
actually we should assume yes we should
be looking at whether what our social
return on investment is and I'd like to
know how we're using that are we using
that across the board or I've only ever
seen it used on one little project so
how we're using how we're showing what
our social would or how we're going to
show what our social return on
investment is thank you chair thank you
just on the latter one social value is
the expression that we tend to bounce
around only because the bit of
legislation calls it social value and
just to give some reassurance again so
that is an area in which I would say the
council's have done some things in the
past and you can point to some examples
particularly around commissioning and
procurement at times but I would say
that it's an area that's as yet not yet
been fully exploited and agree entirely
with that and with that in mind there is
a specific project that this isn't
director for Communities is leading
leading in conjunction with the finance
team in particular around commissioning
and procurement but not restricted to
commissioning and pick Yurman and indeed
Tom Baca and myself for both going down
to visit the Cabinet Office and the DCMS
in the next couple of months to talk
about the work that they've been doing
particularly around social value and how
we can bring that back and make sure
that we get our maximum impact because
ultimately when you ball down everything
that we're doing it is that ultimately
about social value
thank you very much cash the field a
couple of simple questions looking at
the page that says MT FP assets and
investment outputs this one of what the
line reduction of overheads pounds 450
throughout the year was referring to
maybe I should join nematic some but it
doesn't sound too much like it
and the one line below that says phase 1
customer program of efficiencies
achieved but it's spring it's not far
off the spring now I just wondered is
that a major cuss program of
efficiencies and if so spring the seems
pretty quick to do it page it doesn't
have a page no but we the left-hand side
no it does it does 212
Catherine did you wish to comment on the
overheads I think they are numbers that
were built into the budget that was
approved from the current financial year
but I would just need to go back and see
the elements obviously there's probably
a key missing behind the 450 yeah I
think I think we might have achieved 450
pounds but yeah I say I think they were
things that were already built into the
budget that we set for this year
obviously they would happen at different
times during the year
and just as part of me and there is a
customer program and currently being and
currently being developed and and that
is looking at and that you know the next
stage of digital it's looking at and a
reduction in use of paper and reduction
in the use of printing and it's about
the greater you know improving our web
access so it is that whole digital and
web and also more paperless and agenda
and it's about improving and offering
different ways for the customers to
access us and that that will bring
efficiencies and hopefully will also
respond to the the desires of our
community in order to and communicate
with us in different ways thank you does
that mean spring next year or spring
this year well spring goes onto the end
of May if I can assist the the previous
page one 211 sets out a bit more of the
detail okay are there any other
questions
No so we have a proposer in second ah
I'll take a vote please all those in
favor
Thank You MCA 1948 stomachic Football
Club and I'll ask counsel of God please
to tell us about this Thank You Kirsten
um I'm very pleased to present this
report which seeks to support the stay
market sports and social Community
Interest Company which for the sake of
us all I refer to as the CIC from now on
and the CIC incorporates the the stem
market football club omit but good is
intended to provide that support by
securing a long-term lease for their
premises the report recommends a new
50-year lease to be granted from the
council to the CIC which will enable the
football club to apply for FA funding to
improve the grant and facilities and the
CIC are happy to progress on this basis
the council owns just under three acres
of land which forms part of the CIC
grants the larger part of the ground
just over eight acres it is owned by the
stone market Church charity which I'll
refer to as a church here on the council
has a leased from the church for this
part which enables the CIC to use the
land this lease expires in 2025 and the
council pays the church 15,000 a year
for the lease there's no formal lease
between the council and the CIC the
council receives 4,000 pounds a year
from the CIC so the net cost to the
capsule per annum is therefore 11,000
the council has been in discussion
the CIC with the objective of bringing
certain certainty of occupancy for the
football club while ensuring that the
counselors long-term interests are
served the Council on the football club
have agreed an approach in relation to
the council owned land but terms are yet
to be agreed with the church in respect
of their land which is needed to fully
secure the site's future so this report
proposes that the council grants a new
50-year lease to the CIC with a
repairing obligation at a peppercorn
rent the capsule would retain control of
the land but through the lease and at
this point I'll just bring to your
attention of our may a correction that
needs to be made in one of the appended
pended diagrams which I think it's a
second of the diagram which the top
states that the land to be gifted this
is incorrect it is to be leased as the
report says the council will continue
the proposed that the council continue
the existing lease with the church and
then turn into a sublease with the CIC
until the current lease expires in 2025
this would enable a reversionary lease
to be entered into between the church
and the CIC simultaneous to the sublease
and this would secure the required land
for a further 45 years it's recommended
that the council approve the grant of
the church land from the council to the
CIC which is coterminous with the head
lease at an annual rent of four thousand
pounds now
there is a table paper before you which
adds an additional recommendation and
the purpose of this recommendation is to
help achieve agreement between all three
parties and the recommendation proposes
in the event the agreement is not
reached
back to the new sublease and
reversionary lease with the church that
the Assistant Director for assets and
investments in combination with myself
as cabinet member be authorized to agree
an alternative transaction structure in
respect of the church land subject to a
maximum cost of fifty five thousand
pounds and that papers are say is table
tabled to be clear I'll just read that
out if I may so that in the event that
option 3a is not available achieve abbu
due to the lack of agreement with the
stone market Church charities the ad for
assets and investments in consultation
with the cabinet member versus and
investments is authorized to agree an
alternative transaction structure in
respect of the stow market Church
charities owned land subject to a
maximum financial cost of fifty five
thousand pounds so this amended
recommendation or additional
recommendation reiterates our support
for the CIC in their quest to achieve
Football Association funding which does
require commitments or all parties by
the end of February this is a great
opportunity to support the CIC in its
long term aspirations and work together
with the castle for the benefit of the
community and I'm delighted to say that
there are representatives of the state
market football club here with us this
afternoon welcome thank you thank you
and don't have a second to please and
this is for the recommendations of 3 and
3a and we're looking at the three point
four as well and just for clarity I
believe that three point four reduces
the the the eleven thousand a year over
the five year period
Thank You general would you like to do
forget this proposal thank you very much
are there any questions on this can
sorry burn
thank you very much chair um it's good
see it's coming for us I know there's
been discussions with stone market
Football Club for however many years
trying to sort out these um these issues
so um finally but I'm slightly concerned
that in 4.7 it says they needed to do
their decision in March which is next
month so that timeframe is is really
short so I just wanted confirmation that
that the Football Club and the Church
charity as well are able to kind of
resolve these these you know further to
assuming this gets approved today that
they're able to resolve those issues
around that within that time frame and
secondly if I made sure the we know that
we've got that there's a need in stone
market for better footballing obviou
better kind of grounds and kind of
facilities so it's word I'm looking for
better footballing facilities in general
and in fact everyone's jealous of the
need of market
3g pitch in cafe and so on and so forth
so and I just would like confirmation if
I'm a chair on whether there are
discussions between the Football Club
Church mid Suffolk and with the leisure
center about improving footballing
facilities in general across
Rostow market obviously this this'll
lead on if they get the FA funding to to
better facilities but how that will work
with the in in stone market overall
thank you very much sure I can confirm
that
we are working with the Suffolk FA as
well for for their headquarters site and
so on
so that we are we are working with
Suffolk FA set aside to this to ensure
their headquarters and and a 3G picture
it happen instant mark again Emily can I
just confirm that we are actually
working with the Football Club and the
church charities to try and get that
through in the months and yes we are
working with and the church and with the
Football Club and there are three
parties in this discussion so obviously
it's important today that we agree and
the the proposed lease on the council
England and it isn't within my control
to agree on behalf of the church or
indeed the the CIC but that's certainly
our aspiration is to achieve an
agreement within that and timescale are
there any other questions
Councilwoman chair first can I declare
an interest that in 1953 I became a
supporters club member of stoah stoah
market town football club
unfortunately that elapsed after about
15 years when tips which got into the
division one so it's important that we
ensure that the club have a 50-year
lease for all of the land and I think
that is what is planned my question is
can we be assured that that it is
proposed that there will be a 50-year
lease with no break laws or
renegotiation of rent because if it gets
that I mean they need to have 50 years
of security on land that they can afford
to lease
and yes within the report it states that
the the lead from the council will be a
50-year lease at a peppercorn and that
the football club will have repairing
responsibilities during that term so
that's the basis that we've negotiated
in effect thank you any other questions
no I would like just to congratulate
start the football club on the position
in the league they are in at the moment
and I wish them very well for the future
so that's good and I have a proposal a
seconder I'll just take a vote with a
show of hands please all those in favor
and that's unanimous again thank you
very much thank you
move on now to mca 1949 which is the
joint area parking management plan can't
sort of fleming can I ask you to speak
peace thank you very much chairman I'll
give a brief introduction to the area
management plan for civil parking
enforcement and then you know the papers
fairly explanatory that everyone's had a
look at the transfer of civil parking
enforcement for all Suffolk local
authorities from the police will
commence on the 6th of April 20 2014
legislation laid before Parliament in
January this year as part of the
introduction of this new legislation
District Council's are required to set
out their own policies around parking
Suffolk County Council has adopted a
high-level Suffolk parking management
strategy that was in November 2018 in
anticipation of the transfer of
enforcement powers each district now
needs to have regard to that strategy
and set out its own local parking
policies and objectives the Baber
and mid Suffolk joint area parking
management plan has been drafted to meet
these objectives CPE has been running
successfully in Ipswich since 2005 hips
which Borough Council and the district
councils have been working
collaboratively with police and Suffolk
County Council to plan in to implement
the new countywide program to make best
use of economy of scale it was decided
that if switch Borough Council and West
Suffolk Council will jointly jointly
administer or enforce CPE in mid Suffolk
and Babur
East Suffolk administer will administer
CPE within its own boundary the joint
area parking management plan that is in
papers contains broad parking policy
statements which aim to set out what the
parking plan is and what it is intended
to achieve it does not set out specific
proposals for parking restrictions for
any particular areas and nor is it a
blueprint to introduce paid parking
above what is already in place a draft
plan was presented to cabinet in
February last year 2019 that was
followed by stakeholder consultation in
February for a period of six weeks
results of the public consultation have
helped to form the modifications of the
current area parking management plan
which is now ready for final adoption
the vision for the plan is that parking
should be allowed where possible and
controlled where necessary I'm happy to
answer questions if I can and if I can't
I may defer to offices thank you very
much do I have a seconder please yes
chair very happy to a second the
[Music]
can't Silla well um tonight Thank You
chair um yeah my my concern is around
footpaths footways in rural areas
particularly those in front of of houses
in you know you know village built up
areas if I can call them that the
question that I asked of the police and
crime Commissioner was around paragraph
43 in the policy and his this was before
I read this my concern is that if there
is no yellow line and the foots way is
partially obstructed then the police
should come and force if if somebody's
parked outside their house such a bogey
can't get through or even a person can't
walk through we have instances where the
gap between the wall of a property and
the car is insufficient even to walk
through in those instances who can
enforce my understanding is the civil
parking enforcement officer can enforce
is that not um yes would you like to
explain how a police I believe can but
probably won't thank you yes it is a
really tricky area for a parking
enforcement and so I can there is a lot
of gray areas as well so and where there
is a restriction in place so a traffic
rage of regulation order taro there
isn't a problem the civil enforcement
officers can absolutely enforce and
where there isn't a traffic regulation
order
they have no powers so the police do
still hold powers to enforce in certain
aspects I'm not sure what the police and
crime Commissioner replied to your
question but I'm of the understanding
that if there is an obstruction that the
police can enforce chair that is
precisely my understanding however it is
not the answer that the police and crime
Commissioner gave police and crime
Commissioner his answer was that he
would expect the civil enforcement
officer to enforce against parking where
there's no yellow line but the foot way
is partly blocked but sufficiently
blocked to not permit you to walk past
and if there was then a problem which
might occur the concern is that when
people when there is enforcement against
parking in some areas where the our
enforcement officers can enforce some
people knowing that the police are
unlikely to enforce will park in more
dangerous spots on junctions and so on
which and we will not get the benefits
of civil enforcement that we should be
getting and we're leaving aside anything
to do with finance we ought to be able
to regulate parking much better and
enforce against bad parking much better
but unless there is the support from the
police for enforcing where we cannot
enforce we're not going to get the
advantages that we need and I think that
needs to be taken up I've got to have a
question can somebody take that up with
the with the of the police please yes I
would be hard glad to follow that up
there are as Kessler said some areas
here that need refining and I think if
the coming year will provide an
opportunity to do that in particular the
area where it's gray and the police are
the obvious parties to enforce
I guess would you like to add anything
sure yes
just to say that and I would expect any
civil enforcement officer who sees an
obstruction that they can't deal with
legally to be calling the police in that
instance now what what reaction they get
and the time it may take to come out I'm
not sure however I would see is their
job to take some they've got some duty
of ownership of that issue so whether
it's you know if it's clearly a
household possibly knocking on the door
what they can't do is stick a ticket on
they don't have the legislation but they
as far as I'm concerned they're our
ambassadors for positive parking they
should be doing something even if that's
having a conversation with someone if
they're able to to move that car along
and and then secondly absolutely I agree
with councillor Fleming that we can talk
to the police about what those gray
areas are and I know councillor Fleming
is part of the an emerging Suffolk
parking partnership and I would
absolutely encourage Suffolk who were
leading on that to include the police
with in that parking partnership because
clearly there's still an element for
them to play within and parking
enforcement across the foot thank you -
I'm certainly committed to doing that
and any other gray areas I would add
that PCSOs can also issue issue warnings
and advisories although they cannot
enforce either the issue that you're
pointing out to us who can actually give
a ticket which is little bit different
to issuing a warning or a follow-up
which I would hope in a rural area
should be enough to move the offender
along I think you ought to cancel reburn
and then cancel afield please thank you
very much chair this was the question I
was raising that the budget item on
paragraph 6.2 page 230 it says income
from parking car parking fees and
penalty charity notices will be used to
offset the cost of the full parking
function now we earn a fair amount in
parking fees from cut from car parks so
we we earn quite a lot of income from
that so I wouldn't want that just to is
there a limit to how much of that it's
going to be spent on this because it
says this will not cover the full course
well I hope it doesn't cost more than
660,000 which is what it says in the
budget book that we earn from car
parking income so is there a limit on
the you know amount that we will be
spending from car parking fees on this
parking function Thank You chair you're
talking about the parking fees coming in
off the present car parks are you 600 or
yeah yeah as far as I'm aware there is
there is no absolute limit rather in
terms of a number but there is a
practical limit and I think this is this
should be somewhat cost neutral although
that you know remains to be seen whether
it is can I defer to an officer to
confirm that situation because obviously
we can't have unlimited unlimited out of
pocket expenses for CPU yes sir I was
just confirmed with my assistant
director colleague from finance so I
don't have the exact income figures in
front of me however if I can answer more
generally and perhaps take the question
away so we would expect our parking
income to pay for our parking service so
clearly this is just the off-street
element not the on the street and what
I'll have to do is talk to outside of
this if I can to find out exactly what
that income level is and therefore what
any surplus is if that's okay Jay yes
thank you thank you for that Thank You
chair I'm just concerned that we that
you're bringing a policy that's not got
a financial kind of limit is just on it
that's all
it may it chair it may be that that's
been addressed elsewhere but that
um that's what I'm looking for the
conformational thinking it is a
difficult one because obviously parking
illegal parking has caused tremendous
problems not just in the towns but also
in the village areas the parish areas
and there is a special cost but yeah we
don't need it to go too high I agree
with you did you want to come in on that
um no I think we need to take that away
and make sure that that's addressed in a
way that's sensible the parking
management plan will be reviewed it's
not set in stone forever so and there's
a this is the first plan that has been
made and as things evolved which they
will quite quickly I'm sure there'll be
opportunities to update it because the
field solely keep you waiting
not a problem to an extent that lists
the question I was gonna ask just got
asked I was gonna say I'm certainly
concerned that this is looks completely
open-ended and we don't really seem to
have a grasp of where the money is
coming from from pain from this civil
parking enforcement I'm well aware that
the county is putting in the off street
parking sorry the on street parking from
Ipswich and various admins to fund the
first year of this which is something
like eight hundred thousand pounds
that's clearly right across
Suffolk's and not just will not just for
mid suffer but we have to bear in mind a
number of things one that any good
management control would have a plan at
least an intention and understanding
I'll be putting all on street parking
revenues into it which is pockets and
where Suffolk are we putting all the off
street parking revenues in as well is
there some limit to that and what sort
of level of service do we get very in
mind that it's entirely on the goodwill
of the police that it depends whether we
address what might well be the main
problem in rural areas which is people
semi rural areas people parking on pipe
converges and whatever and we've quite
clearly been told that that's not within
the remit of the civil parking officers
so I think lots of people be looking
forward to civil parking enforcement
always certainly have been promising
people at parish councils and I know
other councillors have been doing the
same that are in this room now and when
asked how it will work one speculate
somewhat and says oh I foresee it as all
their cash from parking will disappear
into this bin that may well be wrong we
really need to know exactly where the
position is and leaving it that it was a
lecture not a questioning and I suspect
there will obviously depend on just how
many people are parking illegally didn't
get caught for it and that would you
know shorten the amount of money that
we're paying listen okay come back for a
second no I certainly understand that in
most places the parking fines do not
cover the full revenue costs by any
means and we always could go to Ipswich
and ask and they probably tell us
because they've been doing it for years
who really have a professional sector
and please for the show of hands all
those in favor
thank you
and we move on - sorry you know here
Amelia MCA 1950 the leisure center
proposals mid Suffolk leisure centers
and I'll ask cancel the flight memories
to present and Thank You chair
introduction for leisure investment
proposals from its suffered leisure
centers today I'm seeking support from
cabinet to approve a much-needed capital
investment into our stone market and
Stratford sites during the summer of
2019 an officer and councilor panel
undertook work to determine a potential
capital program the MS LC together with
the ability to introduce the new
outreach program that meets the required
outcomes of the joint cancers leisure
sport and physical activity strategy
adopted by by the adopted in 2017 our
goal is to encourage people who live and
work in favor amid suffer to lead more
active lives keeping active has numerous
benefits not only for physical health
but also for mental well-being it can
help to reduce isolation among older
people instill the importance of
teamwork in children and ease the
symptoms of anxiety and depression
health and well-being is the key to
improving people's quality of life
particularly for those from a
disadvantaged background people who have
physical or learning disabilities and an
increasingly older population our
councillors vision is to support
encourage and inspire our communities to
be more active and this investment will
help us achieve this the recommendations
in this report of 3.1 that cabinet
approves the use of 2.2 million from the
growth and efficiency fund together with
200,000 from existent led existing
leisure facility capital funds to
undertake the proposed development and
refurbishment works 3.22 delegate to the
assistant director environmental and
commercial partnerships in consultation
with the care
remember for communities to undertake a
process to achieve the most economical
advantageous costs to enable the works
to be undertaken 1.3 recommendation to
Council on 27th of February that the
2020 21 capital program and the joint
capital investment and treasury
management strategies 2020 21 be updated
to reflect the financial implications
set out in this report Thank You chair
thank you do I have a seconder council
Richardson Thank You chair I'm very
happy to second the recommendations in
the report thank you very much and again
do we have any questions cancel a vote
um thank you chair just a quick one um
this is great to see this happening but
I just wondered when is it due back so
cabinet at 4.7 it refers to kind of
future work and that's happening I just
wondered when it would be is it that is
it then expected to come back again here
for approval of that work Thank You Chet
at the end of this because it's not it's
a it's not being 20/20 their agreement
that we have with them now and obviously
we need to get going so that as soon as
and we can we can start putting this all
into action and get into the new
equipment in and the updates and moving
that older it's not that old
back to Stradbroke so strapped with
benefits as well Thank You chair if I
may come back in that case my ass the
cabinet remember if she could just
report back when there's been some
significant progress just to keep
members informed Thank You chair I'm
sure we will do that yes absolutely and
I don't know should we set up one of our
by podcast where they
yeah Castlefield
sorry to reveal a little bit negative
state ID issues I'm just scanning
through this again I didn't see any
reference to them is there an issue was
clearly you're providing facilities that
accompany my used to compete with other
gyms etc in the area so I would hope not
but are they
Oh apologies this is conferring again
and so as I understand from my colleague
because this is our own facility we own
the building and we're investing the
money into our own building as opposed
to giving it to a partner who owns the
asset that there is an issue the state
agent any other questions
no in the case we have a proposal and a
seconder I'll take a show of hands for
all those in favor please
that's unanimous
thank you very much
apparently we don't need to take the
item 19 on the agenda because we've
already gone through and no one wanted
to refer to the confidential section of
it so so thank you all very much for
your attendance so I'm calling this
meeting to a close and thank you for
your comments and input